[Music]
the hacker who allegedly stole and
leaked nude photos of over 100 female
celebrities is as I said now being
investigated by the FBI and I'm glad to
hear it but frankly I don't think that
is enough that is why I my own expense
hired a team of computer experts to help
really bring this hacker to justice
that's right folks we hacked the hacker
right let's see how this guy feels about
me sharing his embarrassing photos from
his iCloud like this one of the hacker
practicing unhooking a bra on his cat
enjoying a bubble bath with a blow-up
sex doll begging John Cullen for an
autograph practicing with a bullwhip in
his bedroom
that pictures yours for free by the way
proudly holding up his trophy for first
prize in a regional weirdest penis
contest showing off a very embarrassing
tattoo
and finally it's something to have sex
with a Super Nintendo we see the
bullwhip photo again
can you pull that back up now what's the
other one Jon Gosselin why in the
background is it clearly the guest
entrance to our show how freakin lazy
are we getting around here get a shot
well should we turn slightly this way
yeah don't turn it all
you